[Music]
on this wednesday night the uproar over
an offensive suggestion
the demands for an investigation after a
veterans affairs worker offered
medically assisted death to a former
soldier needing help it's evidently
preposterous disturbing accusations the
ontario doctor hit with new murder
charges
climate crisis we can't just put a
band-aid on this problem the parts of
the u.s left parched at a potential
solution plus zellers 2.0
what's in store for the canadian
retailer
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us calls are growing louder for ottawa
to conduct a fulsome investigation after
global news uncovered a former soldier
seeking treatment for post-traumatic
stress was offered medical assistance in
dying as an option
last night we brought you the exclusive
details of a veterans affairs canada
worker making the shocking suggestion to
the vet seeking help
since then our mercedes stephenson has
heard from outraged advocates and
politicians who say the federal
government needs to take action to
ensure this never happens again here's
our top story tonight
veterans of afghanistan and iraq fought
for canada risking life in limb but
there is a feeling among many that their
country has failed them deny delay
die
i think is how that one goes but
yeah we hear it quite regularly debbie
luther is the executive director of vets
canada a charity that helps veterans in
crisis
she says the commonly heard refrain is a
reflection of veterans low trust in the
system trust that has taken another hit
in the wake of revelations that a
veterans affairs canada employee
presented medically assisted dying to a
veteran with ptsd and a traumatic brain
injury as a potential alternative to
treatment lowther says the conversation
put the veteran at risk they don't want
to
go through with a suicide for fear of
maybe a family member finding them or
whatever
but then they have this opportunity
presented to them the case raises
questions about the training employees
at vac are getting and whether this was
an isolated case
the conservatives are calling for a full
investigation to find out we need to
know how this happened we also need to
know were there other veterans that were
provided this option did any veterans
take the government up on this in canada
medically assisted death can only be
discussed between a primary care
provider like a physician or a
psychiatrist and the patient not a
bureaucrat over the phone
vac does not have any ability to
actually carry out medical assistance in
death but the effect of the incident on
the veterans community has still been
profound what is there to really say
about that
it's it's evidently preposterous
sebastian lavoie served in the canadian
armed forces and as a sergeant major for
the rcmp in british columbia he says the
mentality at vac needs to change when it
comes to how veterans claims are handled
in order to rebuild trust it's almost
like you have to prove it beyond
reasonable doubt and this isn't criminal
threshold here we need to be
conservative on the side of the veteran
ndp critic rachel blaney agrees that
this stunning incident is an opportunity
to look at the systemic shortfalls
facing veterans and make much needed
change it is a symptom of a much larger
and
long-standing problem which is veterans
not getting the supports that need they
need when they need it
pharah we've spoken with the government
today both vac and the minister's office
and they're convinced that this is a
relatively isolated incident from what
they've been able to uncover so far that
it only happened they say as far as
they're aware with this one veteran but
they're concerned so they say if you are
a veteran or know a veteran who this
inappropriate offer has been made to
they want you to reach out to them so
they can look into it and investigate it
it is not something that vac is supposed
to be offering and it's not something
that's capable of carrying out but
obviously it's raising more questions
about how canada treats its veterans
mercedes mercedes-stevenson in calgary
thank you mercedes the federal
government is standing firm on the
decision not to award the country's
highest military honor the canadian
victoria cross to any of the veterans
who served in afghanistan the heroic
actions of private jess la rochelle in
afghanistan in october of 2006 inspired
a public campaign and petition for him
to be awarded the canadian victoria
cross but a review conducted by the
ministry of national defense has decided
that the awarding of canada's second
highest award the star of military valor
was appropriate for la rochelle and the
other 19 recipients
an ontario doctor accused in the death
of a patient is now suspected of killing
three more brian nadler has been charged
with three counts of first degree murder
but as erik sorensen reports nadler's
lawyer says his client says he's
innocent
it was a shock when a doctor at this
hospital in hawkesbury in eastern
ontario was charged with murder last
year now almost 18 months later even
more disturbing that same doctor 35 year
old brian nadler has been charged with
three additional counts of first-degree
murder the original victim said police
was an 89 year old man it sparked an
immediate investigation into other
suspicious deaths the new charges stem
from the deaths of three elderly women
two aged 79 and 93 reportedly died
around the same time as the original
victim in late march of 2021 there are
few details on the other woman who was
80 years old the hawksbury opp crime
unit under the direction of the criminal
investigation branch have arrested and
charged brian nadler age 35 with three
additional counts of first degree murder
nadler was educated at mcgill in
montreal more than 10 years ago did a
residency in alberta and eventually
began working at the hawkesbury and
district general hospital this long-term
care advocate worries that all the
victims were elderly and there's just
so little details that we're hearing but
when you see charges of first degree
murder you can't help it but immediately
think the worst and feel very
frightened for for what these poor uh
you know victims went through what their
families are experiencing right now in a
statement nadler's lawyers said the
allegations against him will be
vigorously defended all four patients
they write died of covet 19 and dr
nadler provided excellent palliative
care when the facts are fully presented
we are confident he will be vindicated
nadler was released on bail last summer
with strict conditions including not
practicing medicine his lawyers say he
has been released on the same terms
today
eric sorensen global news toronto
how we speak to each other is changing
new data from statistics canada shows
canada's linguistic diversity is growing
english and french are still by far the
most common languages spoken by more
than 90 percent of canadians the latest
census figures show a record high number
of people speak a language other than
english or french at home and roughly 9
million canadians have a mother tongue
that is not one of the two official
languages that's a record high since the
question was first asked in 1901 tom
vernon has more on which languages are
seeing the largest increase and what's
driving the evolution
[Music]
every summer in communities across the
country festivals are held to share and
celebrate cultures from around the globe
by those who now call canada home from
traditional dress to food and of course
languages the number of canadians who
predominantly speak
languages other than english and french
at home grew significantly in 2021 one
in four canadians had a mother tongue
other than english or french the highest
number on record and largely driven by
immigration of those other languages
mandarin and punjabi are spoken at home
by the most canadians both exceeding
half a million people in fact south
asian languages like punjabi and hindi
are growing at the fastest rate in the
country the growth rates
of the number of speakers of these
languages
was at least eight times larger than
that of the entire canadian population
language carries culture jillian stevens
is a professor of sociology at the
university of alberta in edmonton who
studies the diversity of languages in
canada and how people in multilingual
communities adapt once the community
starts to lose its language it loses the
easy ties to
historical and even contemporary culture
that isn't an uncommon concern in canada
the residential school system intended
to wipe out indigenous languages and
culture the effects are still being felt
today the census data does show some
potentially promising numbers though
while the overall number of people
reported being able to speak in
indigenous has gone down there are signs
of a resurgence we have an indigenous
language
mother tongue and we speak it at home
it's higher among the young people which
could only add to the growing cultural
mosaic that is canada's voice
tom vernon global news
and good news tonight for anyone wanting
to use their language skills outside of
the country the federal government plans
to open up four new passport pickup
locations in quebec ontario alberta and
prince edward island people submitting
applications that those new centers will
be able to pick up their passports in 10
business days processing backlogs have
been plaguing service canada for months
leading to lengthy wait times
liz cheney once again blasting the
republican personality cult of donald
trump as she conceded defeat in
tuesday's wyoming primary vote
we must be very clear-eyed about the
threat we face and about what is
required to defeat it i have said since
january 6
that i will do whatever it takes to
ensure donald trump is never again
anywhere near the oval office and i mean
it
despite the defeat chaney will remain
wyoming's lone congressional delegate
until january and she'll maintain her
spot chairing the january 6 committee
cheney also hinted at a presidential run
where she would face off against trump
if as expected he announces another run
i'm not going to comment on the grand
jury investigation what do you think
they're ultimately know more about it
reporters swarmed rudy giuliani as he
arrived at an atlanta courthouse today
where he appeared in front of a special
grand jury investigating attempts by
donald trump to overturn his 2020
election loss in georgia giuliani
trump's former personal attorney led
legal challenges to dispute joe biden's
win he repeated baseless claims of
election fraud while urging lawmakers to
not certify biden's victory the former
new york mayor has dismissed the
investigation calling it politically
motivated
severe drug conditions are plaguing
parts of the united states coming up
what washington could do to alleviate
the crisis
plus to the moon
nasa's new rocket that's ready for
liftoff
[Music]
in the u.s southwest drought conditions
are threatening the livelihoods of
millions of americans the colorado river
is drying up and lake mead just east of
las vegas is quickly receding the lake
is the largest reservoir in the u.s in
terms of water capacity but now it's
roughly 18 meters below its usual level
people are using this vertical speed
boat as a measuring tool it was once
completely submerged extreme heat and a
lack of rain are to blame but as reggie
shakini explains decades-old
infrastructure is also making it harder
to avoid arid conditions
at first glance this could almost be the
surface of mars a barren landscape
devoid of any life
but this isn't a distant planet this is
lake mead america's largest reservoir
and its quickly evaporating this is very
high stakes poker we're playing here
rising temperatures are drying up the
colorado river leaving the lake at only
27 capacity this circumstance is unusual
and we haven't seen this intense of a
drought for at least 1200 years there
are huge economic implications if the
water supply starts to be shut off low
water levels won't just impact the
environment and the millions of people
who rely on it it could prevent the
hoover dam from generating electricity
too
the u.s government could take the
unprecedented move of forcing cuts to
water consumption if states can't work
together to reduce usage it in our
authorities to act unilaterally to
protect the system
seven states at the rivers basin have a
yearly allotment of water totaling about
700 cubic meters per second that's about
15 million football fields each roughly
half a meter deep providing water to
about 40 million people
arizona and nevada have already
experienced water cuts california is
exempt for now but not immune science
and the data leads us to now understand
that we will lose 10 percent
of our water supply by 2040. the state's
agriculture sector uses the bulk of lake
mead's water it's now looking to retool
agricultural infrastructure that usually
directs flood waters caused by snow melt
out to sea one way to do that
potentially is to
build a water conveyance and and flood
control system where you can reroute
episodic flood waters clearly we can't
just put a band-aid on this problem
while billions of dollars have been
committed to combat the changing climate
they might only be a drop in the bucket
of what's needed after decades of
drought
regie chikini global news washington
in eastern spain a raging wildfire has
left more than a dozen people injured
this fire brigade is shouting run as the
wind changes and the fire surrounded
them they were scrambling to stop it
from reaching homes in the province of
valencia the nearby villages have been
evacuated two firefighters suffered
burns and at least 11 passengers on a
commuter train traveling through the
area were hurt including four with
serious burns some officials say some
people on board panicked when the train
was engulfed in flames and jumped out
into the fire the train drove backward
to escape spain has endured nearly 400
wildfires so far this year
as the water level continues to fall an
ominous site has emerged from the rhine
and other european rivers these
centuries-old hunger stones carry
messages from the middle ages like if
you see me weep warning that drought
would be inevitable and would be
followed by famine and death in france
the famous loire river has been reduced
to a trickle impassable even for the
region's flat bottom boats the river
flow is at less than five percent of
normal for this time of year the loire
valley known as the garden of france has
experienced four extreme heat waves
already this summer putting its vital
food production at extreme risk
the heat wave gripping most of china has
now lasted 64 days making it the longest
since record keeping began temperatures
topping 40 degrees were recorded around
the country today the heat wave and
resulting drop in water levels in rivers
and reservoirs has led to power cuts to
cities and reduced working hours and
even closures at many factories crops
and livestock are also suffering in this
heat
ahead questionable allegations why a
former bc newspaper editor is being
targeted by hong kong authorities
a former bc newspaper editor has been
declared an enemy of the state by the
government of hong kong victor ho is now
a wanted man after announcing plans last
month to form a hong kong parliament in
exile as the chinese government tightens
its grip there global's imad agahi spoke
to ho about his most wanted status and
how it's not going to deter his efforts
to restore democracy to hong kong ahmad
and pharaoh being a wanted man by
authorities in hong kong is at least for
now not something that will cause victor
ho to live any differently here in
canada because he believes that our
government and the country he calls home
now will protect him
it was through social media that victor
ho who lives in richmond bc learned he
was an internationally wanted man for
what the hong kong security bureau is
calling a breach of national security
law that breach is in relation to ho's
involvement in creating what's called a
hong kong government in exile ho is well
known for his time as the editor of the
singtau daily which is a widely
distributed and successful chinese
language newspaper here in canada
he does not deny involvement in trying
to organize this hong kong government in
exile but adds that this was only a
political concept in its infancy
legislative council now in hong kong is
not a
democratically illegal it is controlled
by the communist government
since they changed
all the rules of game ndp mp jenny kwan
is publicly supporting ho and calling on
prime minister justin trudeau and
foreign affairs minister melanie jolie
to publicly back him and tell the hong
kong government to essentially back off
i think what is really important is for
the canadian government to speak up in
support of victor who's right his
democratic right to free speech
and freedom of thought and beliefs
freedom of the press now although the
official word from the hong kong
security council is that police shall
spare no effort in pursuing these cases
in order to bring the offenders lyco
to justice victor ho tells me that he
has not noticed any change to his
day-to-day life he doesn't suspect that
he may be in danger he is worried about
family abroad facing some harassment and
obviously tells me that international
travel is not something he's looking to
do
for the foreseeable future
farah madaga thank you
retail resurrection next how a faded
canadian discount icon is coming back
from the grave
nasa's new mega moon rocket has rolled
up to its launch pad ahead of its first
flight it took nearly 10 hours for the
artemis one to make the six kilometer
trip it is nasa's most powerful rocket
stretching 32 stories high the rocket
will send an uncrewed capsule around the
moon and back traveling at speeds of 27
000 kilometers per hour the test mission
is expected to take six weeks with
liftoff scheduled for august 29th if the
42-date mission is successful nasa hopes
to return humans to the moon in 2025.
that would be the first time since the
1970s it seems everything old is new
again dust off that old club zed card
the department store zellers is making a
comeback the discount chain is hoping to
unlock those childhood memories of
bargain hunting in a simpler time mike
drollet reports
[Music]
you have to be of a certain generation
for the zeller's tagline to elicit a
smile in the 1990s the low price
retailer had over 350 stores across
canada selling virtually everything get
the commodore 64 computer including the
new geosoftware package 287. but just
like the commodore 64 sellers lost its
luster as well as market share to
walmart and by 2013 closed most of its
storefronts liquidating all its
inventory
oh yeah even its furry mascot zeddy had
to go a camp in waterford ontario
adopted him so you can imagine how
canadians reacted to the news you know
zellers is coming back no really when
well next year in fact the hudson's bay
company has announced a new lease on
life for zellers promising a new online
experience with retail space that will
be allocated from within existing bay
stores what do you remember about
zellers the most he's not the shopper no
i don't remember the name you just
remember i dragged him in and out but he
wasn't paying attention so the question
is why now well for one prices have gone
up because of inflation so there's a
demand for low-cost alternatives but
there's also an old marketing ploy the
bay appears to be using
nostalgia is something that consumers
have but for some brands so if you're a
baby boomer uh and you remember back to
the summer of love and you know slapping
on your levi's jeans and and getting
into that little volkswagen van and
heading off to a rock concert a lot of
nostalgia there
[Music]
and certainly canadians have fond
memories does anybody else remember the
hot chicken sandwich but what else did
zeller sell that was specific to zellers
what are the iconic items from zellers
that you want to buy i can't think of a
thing maybe all that matters is the
belief that the lowest price is the law
mike you're like global news toronto
i still remember that smell of fries and
gravy i wonder if they're going to bring
the diner back that's global national
for this wednesday night we're going to
leave you with the rescue of duke the
dog the golden retriever cut his paw on
sharp rocks while walking with his owner
on mount seymour north of vancouver well
duke couldn't make it down the mountain
so he hitched a ride on a helicopter and
on someone's back thanks so much for
watching and spending your evening with
us until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and each other good night
[Music]
that's